à nous allons parler d'une collection
avec sonia rykiel mais attention pas le
genre de collection pour qu'elle vous a
habitués nous allons parler d'une
collection de mots collection de mots
extrêmement recherchés judicieusement
pensé des mots qui d'ailleurs en sont
venus à former un véritable livre au
titre d'ailleurs qui mérite d'être
expliqué quand on a fait une partie de
sa carrière dans le texte dans le
textile puisque vous avez intitulé votre
livre et je la voudrait nu oui
symboliquement j'imagine c'est pour ça
que c'est important sujet
c'est une espèce de d'équivoque entre
cet habit qui est quelque chose de
d'enveloppés et cette envie certainement
que j'ai d'être développés alors je dis
tout de suite ceux qui sont tentés par
ce genre de lecture qui ne s'attendent
pas à trouver des anecdotes
croustillantes sur celles qui ont été
vos clientes
elle a beaucoup de connu sur vous même
c'est la somme à la fois d'une vie
intérieure d'une expérience
professionnelle et d'une expérience
féminine avec de très jolies formules
que je me suis permis de relever par
exemple vous dit
le noir est une couleur un des centres
quand on le porte bien oui mais c'est
une formule il ya beaucoup de phrases
comme ça de mode d'espèces de
ça veut dire parce que le noir est la
couleur du deuil que il faudrait le
porter qu'ils aient l'humilité il faut
pas chercher à comprendre vraiment je
crois qu'il faut lire et qu'il faut
commander rage rentrée dans un décor
rentrer dans un corps où vous rentrez
dans un vêtement ou rentrer dans un
espace je crois pas du tout qu'il faille
chercher exactement ce que ça veut dire
je crois que j'ai joué en effet avec les
mots comme j'ai joué avec l'habit comme
je joue avec les odeurs comme je joue
avec les espaces comme une femme et avec
une espèce de comment dirais-je de de
fascination et d'envoûtement qui m'a
profondément ravi alors si je n'ai pas
tout compris dans votre livre et je suis
heureux d'avoir été fidèles à votre
propre au vent cela au moins 1h
découvert qu'il pouvait exister des
rapports passionnels entre le vêtement
est celui qui les portait c'est normal
parce que je pense que ceux qui a
l'audace de s'approprier votre peau en
fait il faut vraiment que vous l'aimiez
profondément et passionnément
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où un
vêtement est une double cher une double
peau il faut vraiment que vous lui
donniez ce que vous avez de plus profond
pour qu'il projette justement ce que
vous avez envie d'être
et je crois que quand tant qu'on n'a pas
compris ou tant qu'on n'a pas adoré ce
vêtement on ne peut pas vivre avec lui
comme avec un amant et je crois qu'il
faut vivre de cette façon là que leur
délire vous aller plus loin et que vous
dites qu'il faut avoir envie de le
mettre mais aussi envie de l'enlever
c'est pas qu'il faut avoir envie
d'enlever je crois qu'il faut qu'ils
provoquent l'envi de vous l'enlever mais
encore faut-il trouver de la main
d'oeuvre c'est pas spécialisés pourquoi
et non non mais je dis ça va ça va à
partir du moment où le vêtement est un
appel et où le corps est un appel je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de problème alors
vous dites aussi le mensonge c'est la
création c'est pas de moi je ne sais
plus si c'est pascal victor hugo qu'il a
dit
il a dit mentir nesta créé je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse créer sans mentir je
pense que la création c'est une
surabondance
c'est un développement c'est une c'est
quelque chose c'est une
c'est un amoncellement il est en dehors
d'elle à laquelle vous vous êtes livrés
et dont vous parlez et qui alors là
constitue vraiment un mensonge c'est le
parfum pourquoi récemment change c'est
pareil le parfum c'est comme c'est comme
une écharpe qui suit c'est comme les
mots qui suivent
ça fait partie complètement de la chair
si on sion il mais on imagine que le
vêtement est une double peau on peut
très bien imaginer que le vêtement est
une double cher puisqu'il est encore
plus près de la peau et qu'il faut
justement qu'il soit suffisamment fort
et suffisamment près de vous pour vous
envelopper c'est pas un mensonge le
parfum je pense que le la création est
un mensonge
il n'y est la création scientifique qui
n'est pas un mensonge et je pense que
tous les créateurs sont menteurs monteur
d'origine de tempérament et
obligatoirement terre on peut pas on ne
peut pas créer son en tire d'ailleurs je
trouve que mentir c'est consacrer le nom
sacré et c'est très important
alors j'imagine qu'après des débuts
aussi éclatant dans l'écriture vous avez
récidivé parce que vous avez pris
certainement le goût du mot juste de la
phrase bien coupé j'espère que
j'écrirais que je continuerai à écrire
parce que j'y ai trouvé là quelque chose
de complètement enivrant et de
complètement juste pour moi dans le
vêtement
je ne vais jamais jusqu'au bout je ne
vais jamais jusqu'au bout parce que je
ne suis pas responsable en entier de ce
que je fais je suis toujours avec les
choses qui n'arrivent pas vraiment bien
c'est à dire des couleurs qui ne sont
pas juste des matériaux qui ne sont pas
justes dans l'écriture je suis allé
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout du mot
jusqu'au bout de la signature j'ai signé
et c'est vraiment moi on aura un
excellente surprise en découvrant ce
livre qui va beaucoup plus loin que la
façon de s'habiller